[Music]
in the loud house they show their love
by ducking dodging pushing and shoving
and by saying plenty of inappropriate
jokes some of these episodes have scenes
that would never be approved by your
parents we took your suggestions and
explored 10 and appropriate loud house
episodes stay tuned for number 10 the
episode only true loud house fans have
heard of if you're new here hit that
subscribe button to never miss another
video and don't forget to give us a big
thumbs up let's explore some more loud
house episodes that weren't meant for
kids
frog wild let's start with frog wild
which was an episode suggested by a
youtube user called I'm a chubby hamster
we're pretty sure a lot of adults would
get completely grossed out by this
episode - or at least by the theme of it
in this episode mrs. Johnson tells the
class they'll have to dissect frogs
we're sure you had to do that in school
already and the loud siblings are no
different while Lincoln is really
excited Alana shows him how she met her
pet frog hops she makes a point that
frogs are cooler on the outside than
they are on the inside
Lincoln agrees and decides to go on a
rescue mission to save the frogs from
being dissected Tim and Lana end up
saving the frogs and making a froggy
fortress in the classroom where all
frogs can be seen happily playing and
jumping around at the very last scene of
the episode a kid points to the fortress
and asks what are the two frogs doing
mrs. Johnson suddenly freaks and tries
to cover the glass to stop the kids from
seeing something that definitely wasn't
meant for their eyes what do you think
should frog wild be on the list or were
you able to watch the episode without a
problem make sure to let us know in the
comments and suggest even more
inappropriate episodes to get a shout
out just like I'm a chubby hamster L is
for love this episode might not be that
controversial but we're pretty sure no
parents would want their children to get
anonymous letters and decide to take
matters into their own hands you be the
judge
shoutout to JJ 1014 for suggesting this
episode L is for love is a super cute
episode in it the kids receive an
anonymous love letter addressed through
L loud which pretty much means it could
be a letter for any of them considering
all their names start with the letter L
to find out who's behind the letter the
siblings decide to approach their
crushes and send them signals to let
them know they perceive the message well
except for Luna who's too shy to
approach anyone called Sam they start
getting more letters and as soon as the
letter mentions sweet sounds and all
things British the kids immediately
discover that they're intended for Luna
they all go to the British restaurants
where they are supposed to meet the
creator of the letter however it turns
out that it was their parents who have
been singing each other letters we also
get to find out that Sam is a girl but
that's not what's weird about the
episode if a child receives an anonymous
letter that tells them to go meet
someone somewhere they should definitely
tell their parents first we're sure all
parents agree that the episode is just
teaching children to take matters into
their own hands potty mouth potty mouth
can also be seen as a completely
innocent episode but we're here there
are a lot of fussy parents who have
something to say about this storyline
potty mouth is all about well potty
mouth when their parents go to the mouth
to pick out an appropriate time because
they're going to be interviewed by the
daycare academy the kids decide to watch
TV and that's when Lily lets out a sound
that Lucy describes as the D word as
soon as she says it all kids are totally
shocked
now remember this is a cartoon for kids
so it shouldn't really have any curse
words of any nature the next few Clips
show the loud kids in various situations
where they got angry and it seems like
really learned that specific word from
them if it wasn't appropriate for Lily
it probably wasn't appropriate for the
kids to be saying it either Lisa even
listens to a song with censored lyrics
and we know is something that rhymes
with the word planet the kids realize
that it's them who have taught really
the bad word and decide they have to
behave better so that Lily can imitate
better behavior the episode might be
hilarious but we're pretty sure a lot of
you have wanted to repeat those words or
even say something worse wait until you
hear what Lily actually said space
invader all right there would be
absolutely nothing wrong with space
invader if it wasn't for the
inappropriate joke that was apparently
too much to handle for British TV stay
tuned to hear what happened in space
invader Lin and Lucie have a fight and
as the two have shared their room
Lincoln is kind enough to share his room
with Lin to let her cool off Lin isn't
really impressed
by lincoln's room but Lincoln's tired
face says it all after Lynne claims that
there's a total lack of balls in his
room there's a small pause before she
continues and says there's a good thing
she brought her own balls we bet that
all adults were able to understand that
joke much better than any kid would and
many would agree that this is just a
little bit too inappropriate for a
children's show and that's not all in
the UK version of the same episode the
small paws and Lincoln's tired face are
completely removed
see even Nickelodeon thinks these jokes
are inappropriate for kids not to
mention just how mean and ungrateful
Lynne was when Lincoln offered her his
room her attitude in this episode
definitely shouldn't be copied by any
child what do you think did Lynn go too
far or is the UK Nickelodeon just a
little bit sensitive the loudest yard
the loudest yard is an innocent episode
but we bet some parents might have
something to say about it especially
since the specific and appropriate scene
happened right at the beginning
read-aloud criticizes her son for
sitting inside and playing videos all
day and in the next scene he gets
distracted by the arcade during a power
walk with his dad what can we say
this is Halle Lincoln is he loves video
games more than anything and he
absolutely hates being outside but the
next scene is what's most disturbing
about this entire episode we see Rena
doing a home workout and Talley Lincoln
that exercise is fun if you stop the
scene here and showed it to any parent
they probably think this episode is
completely inappropriate
it sure looks that way until the next
take shows that Lincoln has actually
taped a comic book to his mom's behind
and is now reading it while pretending
he's working out it's not one of our
favorite episodes but it's also not the
worst one hand me down Oh hand me down a
is an important lesson for kids but
there's a scene that will probably scar
you for life and you'll never be able to
look at Lori without noticing this
detail Lincoln isn't happy when he
received a hand-me-down bike from Lori
which is too girly for him he ends up
taking Lin's bike which ends up getting
stolen the entire episode is an
important lesson in here me downs and
how the loud kids personalize the
hand-me-down they received from older
siblings but there's just one part
that's slightly bizarre and it will end
up staying with you forever
after Lincoln accuses Lori that she
never had to deal with hand-me-downs
because she's the oldest Laurie shares
an income
fact we really didn't want to know she
says at her iconic blue tank top we
always see her where is actually her
mom's old girdle her statement makes her
siblings grown and discussed and we can
totally see why a girdle is a piece of
underwear women wear to give an
appearance of a slim down waist just
think about it Lori is actually wearing
her mom's old underwear as a tank top
we're pretty sure you won't stop
thinking about it every time you see
Lori it's a piece of information we
never needed to know and we'd happily
live without it back in black
Nickelodeon managed to squeeze in a lot
of inappropriate jokes in the loud house
and you probably never even notice them
it's exactly why we think these episodes
were definitely not meant for kids
Lincoln's friend rusty makes a pretty
funny joke in the first scene of back in
black we see Lincoln finishing his solar
system model when rusty joins him at the
door along with his younger brother then
Lincoln asks rusty if he brought Uranus
and rusty says he never leaves home
without it Lincoln might be talking
about the planet but it looks like rusty
is definitely not talking about the
Uranus you can find in the solar system
or maybe he is just in a different way
another character who's probably scarier
than ever in this episode is Lucy who
developed a crush on Rusty's younger
brother rocky between Lucy's sudden
obsession with rocky and Uranus this
episode could definitely be toned down
just a bit
serial offender serial offender is a
very interesting episode but we're not
sure how well would go down with parents
we all know kids sometimes can't behave
especially in a public setting like a
grocery store it seems like there would
be a lot of fun causing havoc around the
store
besides it's never a good idea to let
kids as old as the loud children go
shopping completely by themselves but
Lincoln wants to get the new type of
cereal and convinces his mom to go
shopping by himself
of course his sisters have to come along
and that's when the problems start
although the episode is funny no
parent would ever want their children to
behave in the same way to grocery store
but the cherry on top is the scene where
Lincoln picks up canned tomatoes all of
the sudden Lynne comes screaming down
the aisle saying give me Calle market
shoppers children watching won't know
what that means but we guarantee that
most adults would have to do a double
take
to make sure they haven't heard Lynn say
a terrible word let's just say that in
this case Nickelodeon did a play on
words and market shoppers actually meant
something completely different that's
definitely not meant for kids get the
message get the message has an
interesting scene that shows a quick
animation mistake if you pause at the
right time but the episode itself is
just all kinds of bizarre especially the
beginning where Lincoln seems to be
playing as the art game where he fights
off zombies with breakdancing
sure it's breakdancing but we've never
seen someone do the infamous 14 as they
breakdance it seems highly inappropriate
for a child to be doing that in a video
game and Lincoln makes things worse as
he says the zombie will fill his twork
and cause him an evil jerk we all know
kids like to get temperamental
they play video games but we're sure
parents wouldn't want to encourage their
kids using language like that what do
you think but your parents allow you to
shake it like Lincoln does just so you
can fight off zombies make sure to watch
our videos on animation errors in the
loud house to see where you can spot a
very simple but interesting illustration
mistake it happens in the next scene as
Lincoln dances his way up to Lori's room
and let's just say that she's not very
happy about it did you like get the
message let us know in the comments
enough is enough and finally if there's
an episode that's definitely not meant
for children it's the one that hasn't
aired at all shoutout to gamer X cam who
pointed out that we should definitely
mention this episode - enough is enough
as a mysterious episode that was
supposed to be the third season finale
but it was completely scrapped after the
final production was already finished it
was discovered by someone who found a
website with lost pieces of media such
as the leave episodes and other fun
facts of course this story could be
easily made up but will let you be the
judge enough is enough is a dark episode
with a much more serious storyline than
any other episodes from the loud house
the episode starts off with the wind
making fun of Lincoln using puns and
laughing it off Lincoln had enough of
her jokes and let's just say he let his
video game temper get to him the rest of
the storyline revolved around an
alternative way Lincoln reacted to his
sister's loud and obnoxious behavior and
the scenes were definitely not meant for
kids let's just say when the episode
ended the loud family no longer had
eleven kids it's a dark storyline that
was most likely made up but if it wasn't
we definitely see why it was never aired
what do you think was Enoch is enough
just a fanfiction or is the story real
and that's it for our video for more
videos like this one check out 10
mistakes in the loud house you might
have missed see you next time
[Music]